نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد انخفاض جديد لسعر
الجنيه المصري الى مستوى قياسي جديد كسر
حاجزه 30 جنيه مقابل الدولار الواحد هذه
الانتكاسه جاءت مصحوبه بارتفاع معدل اسعار
المواد الغذائيه نتيجه انخفاض قيمه العمله
المحليه ونقص العمله الاجنبيه حيث افاده
صندوق النقد الدولي بان المركزي المصري في
او المصري سوف يلتزم بسماحي لسعر الصرف بل
بان يعكس ظروف العرض وطلب على العملات
الاجنبيه لكنه قد يتدخل في اوقات المفرد
باسعار الصرف دون اللجوء استخدام الاصول
الاجنبيه الصافيه للبنوك بقصد تثبيت سعر
الصرف وهنا اشار مراقبني سياسه التعويم
التي لها المركزي المصري كان لا مفر منها
نتيجه الازمه الاقتصاديه ووفق الخبراء
فتعويمه ضروره في هذه المرحله بسبب نقص
نقد الاجنبي وارتفاع الاستيراد من يفوق
تصدير فيما يرى البعض ان التعويم في ظل
الوضع الاقتصاديه متدني سوف يؤدي لرفع
الاسعار بشكل كبير وسيزيد من تدهور قيمه
الجنيه المصري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نفهم اكثر هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من
القاهره الدكتور فخري الفقهي مساعده
المدير التنفيذي لصندوق النقد الدولي
سابقا اهلا بك معنا دكتور فخري دكتور فخري
تعويم او تحرير الجنيه المصري وفتح المجال
امام الطلب والعرض حتى تضبط هذه الطريقه
سعر الجنيه مقابل الدولار في هذه المرحله
هل كان ضروريا تعويم الجنيه المصري مره
اخرى
تحياتي لكيي
والساده المشاهدين فيما يتعلق
بتحرير سعر صرف الجنيه المصري تم في 27
اكتوبر الماضي عندما حصلت مصر على موافقه
على مستوى الخبراء او موافقه مبدئيه على
مستوى الخبراء صندوق النقد الدولي في هذه
الحلقه تم تحديث سعر الصرف الجنيه المصري
يعني ارتفع من
تقريبا 19 جنيه
للدولار الى
24.7 جنيه للدولار ثم بعد ذلك همم عندما
حصلت مصر على الموافقه النهائيه بعد اكثر
وما يخرج من شهرين من مجلس التنفيذي
واشنطن في هذه الحاله ارتفع مره ثانيه من
و70 قرش الى 27 وهمم 60 قرشنا همم ده فيما
يتعلق ده تسريع وتيره ال- همم مرونه سعر
وليس تم تحريره منذ اكتوبر الماضي لكن ما
يحدث الان هو عمليه همم يعني همم يعني
اصبح اكثر مرونه في هذه الحلقه كذلك عندما
يعني
اليوم وجدنا ان هناك تسريع لوتيره تحرير
سعر الصرف او يعني مرور السعر الصرف في
هذه الحاله حتى بلغ ما يزيد عن ال 30 جنيه
للدولار
وزاد عن ال 32 في اثناء التعامل اليوم في
الجهاز المصرفي على الاحوال يعني
الاستهداف الاستهداف البنك المركزي الان
ينحصر في محاربه التضخم والغلاء لانه
تاثيراته على تاثيراته على النسيج
الاجتماعي في هذه الحاله همم يعني هي محل
اهتمام البنك المركزي للدرجه الاولى اللي
هو لانه معدل التضامن يعني
حتى نفهم بطريقه كذلك مبسطه بالنسبه
مشاهدينا يعني يقول البعض بان التعويم وهو
ليس التعويم الاول في عهد الرئيس السيسي
هو تعويم الثاني ولكن سبق للرحل انور
السادات انعومه في 1977 للرئيس همم حسني
مبارك كذلك في 2003
العمليات هذه المره يقول البعض بان
السلبيات قد تكون اكثر من الايجابيات فيتش
مثلا همم صنفت همم مصر سلبي بعد ان كان
التصنيف مستقر فحضرتك تكمل ايجابيات التي
تراها ربما في المدن المتوسط الى البعيد
بعد عمليه التحرير الاخيره هذا
اييي يعني دعيني اشير لانه يعني اساسيات
الاقتصاد المصري سليمه لكن هي ما حدث هو
ندره النقد الاجنبي مع طبعا التدعيات ازمه
روسيا الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ولو ان
تداعيتها خفت كثيرا اللي هو اسعار الطاقه
انخفضت بشكل يعني ملفت للنظر بالاضافه
اسعار الحبوب الى اخره لكن تبقى المتبقي
في هذه الحاله تدعيته وخروج الاموال
الساخنه من مصر بمقدار 22 مليار خلال
اربعه اشهر السابقه هذه النظره في النقد
الاجنبي ادت الى اتخاذ بعد القرارات التي
ادت الى ظهور
طوابير او قوائم انتظار للسلع الموجوده في
الموانئ لا يوجد يعني الدولار الكافي
للافراج عنها في هذه الحاله ده معناه انه
فيه طلب غير مشبع او غير كافي لافراج عن
هذه البضاعه الموجوده في الجمارك تصل كانت
تصل الى 15 او 14.5 مليار تم تدبير يعني
تقريبا النص او اكثر من نصف قليلا ف- بقي
في البضاعه طبعا مستلزمات انتاج للمصانع
وسلع استراتيجيه وبعض السلع الاخرى تقدر
بسبعه مليار نحتاج في هذه الحاله البنك
المركزي يحتاج الى سبعه مليار دولار اذا
من نظره النتيجه عن خروج الاموال الساخنه
كانت يعني سببا رئيسيا في ما حدث وارتفاع
معدلات تضخم لان ندرس النقد الاجنبي
معناها ندره في الاستيراد وبالتالي
المعروض من السلع ومستلزمات الانتاج
المصانع ادت الى زياده التكلفه وارتفاع
دكتور فخري صحيح طيب نظره العمله الاجنبيه
همم تراجعها او عدم وجود عدم توافرها هو
الذي دفع معه بتحرير همم سعر الصرف ولكن
ما الذي يضمن ان تتوفر هذه العمله بعد هذا
الاجراء بعد تعويم الجنيه
لوضع نظرنا قليل او نظرنا الى انه ما يحدث
في مصر شان باقي الدول العالم هي ازمه
اقتصاديه عالميه ناجمه عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هذه الازمه الاقتصاديه ادت الى
خروج الاموال الساخنه من 45 اقتصاد ماشي
على المستوى العالم يكفي الاشاره الى ان
صندوق النقد الدولي في تقرير له بانه ثلث
اعضاء صندوق النقد الدولي او بمعنى اخر ما
يزيد عن 65 دوله اعضاء من الصندوق اللي
بيقدر اعدادهم كعضاء 190 دوله 65 دوله
وثلث الاعضاء يعانون معاناه شديده من
ضمنها مصر في هذه الحاله وعديد من الدول
الاخرى منها دول عربيه ما عدا دول الخليج
بتطبع ولذلك بنقول في هذه الحاله هذه
الظروف هي خارجه عن اراده هذه الدول
اخر سؤال دكتور فخري همم
عنها هذا الاجراء الاخير تعويم كلي اي ان
هناك حريه مطلقه في عمليه العرض والطلب
التي ستحدد سعر العمله او هو تعويم جزئي
وان البنك المركزي سيبقى في متابعه هذا
الموضوع اذا ما تضررت العمله الوطنيه
لدينا برنامج مع صندوق النقد الدولي لمده
اربعه سنوات همم تم الاتفاق على ان يكون
هناك تعويم مزيج من التعويم الحر ولكن
يمكن البنك المركزي
التدخل في حاله الى منفلت سعر الصرف اما
هو بشكل يستطيع ان يتدخل باداره
الدكتور فخريه مساعد والمدير التنفيذيه
لصندوق النقد الدولي السابقه شكرا لك
دكتور دكتور
غدا في نفس التوقيت ملفات اخرى دائما
للنقاش السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]